hello there fellow traveler of the
internet and welcome to this fabulous
collection of theories all revolving
around the character known as tingle for
those of you who are unfamiliar with the
individual himself allow me to introduce
you or refresh those repressed memories
of just who this funny little man is
tingle is a short man who wears a funny
little suit that's much too tight for an
individual of his stature claiming his
outfit makes him a fairy he's
middle-aged being confirmed across
several games to be 35 years old now I
hear you asking what in the world is a
short middle-aged ferryman doing wearing
green and red tights and telling
children his magical words
well mr. tingle happens to be a mapper
and is quite good at it actually you
first meet the man in majora's mask when
he's flying high above the earth
attached to a red giant balloon why is
he up there you ask well like I told you
he's making maps he's made other
appearances in several main Zelda titles
such as but not limited to Wind Waker
where he's a map translator for swords
adventures where he tries to steal force
gems from you and the Minish Cap where
he and his brothers will fuse kin stones
with you tingle is also the star of his
own spin-off games known as mm hmm
freshly picked tingles rosy rupee land
try saying about when five times as
quickly as you can
and ripened tingles balloon trip of love
both of which focus around tingle and
his fellow companions now a character as
ridiculous as tingle often provides more
questions than answers as to why he
appears the way he does and why exactly
he does anything that he ends up doing
in all the games it is for this reason
that I have compiled a fabulous
collection of tingle theories for you
all to watch and enjoy and now without
further ado please watch and and joy
perhaps the most well known theory about
the little green fairy man is that
tingle is a murderer I know I'm starting
off strong but as a wise man probably
once said why the heck not in the game
Wind Waker which was a lot of people's
first and most notorious introduction to
tingle you first find the man in prison
no joke he's holed up in prison on
windfall
island-y you asked for stealing a Pictou
box from the man named Lenz oh now I
hear you wondering
just because he's a thief that doesn't
make him a killer right where's the
proof of that well in the game when you
released tingle from his jail cell and
in return have full access to his former
living quarters there's a peculiar
movable crate sitting against the wall
in good old Zelda fashion when you push
said crate from the wall lo and behold
there's a hidden pathway behind it
obviously we've got to explore this tiny
tingle sized hidden crawlspace to see
what it leads to
upon crawling through the twists and
turns we eventually emerge into a
strange open area with a chest in the
middle of it but what's this
there are skulls along the wall human
skulls now I suppose it's possible that
tingle is merely making use of the
already dug out secret chamber filled
with already dead human skulls in order
to hide his pick doh box away but that
all seems awfully convenient now doesn't
it it's also unrealistic that the secret
cross face would be hidden away with an
ordinary-looking crate before tingled
was even there surely whoever runs this
jailhouse would have noticed that prior
to housing another criminal in the cell
meaning tingle himself dug this crawl
space until he found in opening this
could explain why some of his tunnels
appear to lead nowhere or lead to trap
doors whether it be to find a secret
opening or to throw off pesky intruders
either way it means tingle himself dug
this tunnel but how would he transport
the bodies of his murder victims through
that teeny-tiny crawlspace well I can
only answer that with a question we
don't see the full skeletons now do we
only the skulls a head is much more
transportable than an entire body but
what did he do with the bodies then who
knows maybe we'll never know or maybe we
already do Linux theory is that tingle
is linked from another dimension aside
from the fact that he's obsessed with
link himself and in fairies and like
it's revealed to us in the games that
sadly never made it to the US that
tingle is not tingles real name
in fact we don't actually know his real
name tingle is just a title that's given
to a chosen hero a hero that is then
clad in green and defeats evil in the
game bla bla bla rosy rupee land tingle
is chosen by an entity known as old man
repeat to collect as many rupees as
possible and give them to old man rupee
thus turning tingle into tingle along
his quest he has a fairy companion whose
name is Pinkel and if he collects all of
the rupee goods in the game Pinkel will
give tingle a fantastic boost to the
final boss fight a quest mechanic and
pert that's very similar to Lynx fierce
deity mask in Majora's Mask the boss
fight by the way his old man repeat
himself who is actually an evil demon of
course there are pieces missing to this
theory such as Howard tingle now be in
our dimension if he came from another
dimension and is he even from another
dimension because we can clearly see
that he has family members like a father
in majora's mask and brothers in several
of the other games cook these tingled
spin-offs be nothing more than just a
fever dream perhaps I mean in balloon
trip of love tingle meets up with
essentially the same characters from The
Wizard of Oz and even follows a yellow
brick road but it definitely bears some
thought after all if the name tingle is
actually a title and not a name couldn't
there be multiple tingles out there alas
the world may never know
another theory notably coined first by
Nintendo tuber dr. wily is that tingle
is a God now dr. wily goes much more
in-depth with this particular theory
than I'm going to go in just a second so
I'll actually link to his video in the
description below in the case that
anyone wants to watch the original
Theory video basically the theory states
that in the game of the Wind Waker which
a lot of tingle theories originate from
there is a tale of our beloved tingle
hidden away within the Tower of the Gods
oh you're saying you played Wind Waker
and you don't remember this hidden
message well that's because it's not
just hidden away from plain sight it's
hidden away from the game itself in
order to actually read the message you
need to use the
the dungeon which is a strange little
device that allows you to connect your
gameboy advance to your GameCube console
in order to actually control tingle
himself and unlock unique abilities and
bits of dialogue and other tingled
centric stuff most of which are just
plain hilarious if you use this device
within the tower of the gods
you can stumble upon multiple pieces of
a legendary tale that when pieced
together the text talks about the events
of the tingle from majora's mask and
calls him a fairy this could easily be
tingle talking about himself of course
but what's strange about all this is the
fact that this legend is scattered about
within the Tower of the Gods which goes
without saying as a sacred sealed away
place that very very few have ever
traversed or even seen much less tingle
himself the other strange detail
regarding this legend is that it details
a tingle from a completely different
timeline furthermore the events of that
specific game in that specific timeline
can only possibly be known by link or
tingle himself since the game took place
in termina a land where only link and
now apparently tingle have been 2
dr.wily concludes mostly from these two
strange facts that the same multi
thousand-year-old tingle must have
placed the legend there himself and that
by extension must mean link is some sort
of timeline hopping fairy or other deity
what if the magical words tingle tingle
Kulu limp are actually altering reality
every time he says them if that thought
makes you a bit nervous don't worry
you're definitely not alone but who
knows a tingle ruled reality may
actually spice things up a bit
my final theory in this fabulous little
collection of theories is a bit more
factual than it is theoretical but since
it hasn't officially been confirmed in
any of the games it's still considered
just a theory this one is about tingle
being a slave owner or a slave driver
once again in the game wind waker if you
visit tingles island after freeing him
from windfalls jail you'll be met with
of course the man himself but also some
other individuals that haven't been seen
before tingles younger brother ankle and
a complete stranger
David jr. both are dressed exactly alike
to tingle changing only his color
palette but while ankle openly admits to
being tingles younger brother David jr.
has this to say instead
this guy here and I are complete and
utter strangers I kid you not now why
would this complete an utter stranger be
here working for tingle on tingle island
with tingles brother according to the
David jr. figurine David jr. son of
David senior is a sailor who was once in
search of the fabled treasure within the
ghost ship
he was taken one night by strong drink
however and ended up talking at tingle
Island in a drunken stupid when he woke
up according to his own words he was
dressed inexplicably in the tingle gear
and his ship was gone and he's been
forced to work for tingle ever since
what exactly happened when he was drunk
on that night can't be known for sure
but one thing is certain he is currently
being held against his will the poor man
wants nothing more than to be allowed to
leave these crazy brothers behind and
resumed his seaworthy quest but alas he
is a slave to the master of the island
tingle himself you know if link wasn't
such good business for tingles map
deciphering I wonder if the same would
have happened to him so what do you guys
think which theory is the most
believable or is there another theory
out there even more believable let me
know in a comment below thank you so
much for watching and let me know if you
guys want to see more compilation videos
like this one in the future along with
maybe what character you'd like me to
cover next
as always huge thank you to my fabulous
patreon tingles you guys are truly the
best of the best
follow the link in the description below
to learn how to get your name up here at
the end of each of my videos also in the
description below is my amazing discord
server invite so if you want to chat it
up with the best of us be sure to check
it out that's all I've got for you this
time so without further adieu this is
mass Nintendo tingled signing out peace
[Music]